how did you get past security I came in
the back there are no doors in the back
of the
pom I never said I use the
door I had only been in Palm Beach 2
weeks we don't know you I'm Maxine Dort
but I already knew the Palm Royale the
most exclusive club in the world was
where I belonged Evelyn you are the
woman to know in Palm
Beach I don't IQ Maxine you're very good
at making things awkward I don't concern
myself with the shenanigans of vapid
po what is Evelyn wearing
sleeves you know anything about rich
people I parked on the
lawn Robert shake me another martini and
then let's play
doctor do you work Maxine God no you
want to work God no you really want all
this more than anything I've ever wanted
in my whole life like to take a few
pictures Maxine you're the lead story I
see us all as one
Sisterhood are people looking for
something new let me tell you something
about the Palm Royale it's a nightmare
and that's all thanks to you don't
underestimate adelic Court I would
never Palm Beach is just a shell game
everybody has a secret you two
behave you don't have to have money the
blackmail is right here you don't know
the half of it what you the fires a
pale's pit is going on here off we
[Music]
go you're in over your head my girl you
don't even know
it I am never in over my head it would
be disrespectful to my hairdresser T
shame CU nobody wants you when in Palm
Beach a secret is like a loaded gun no
no no no you never know when it will go
off for who it might
hit
ladies I know yes surprised to see me
considering you left me for dead there
be some
changes
made
[Music]